hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
with no clips so here's some perfect BS
from CNN comet saying you know they work
at the margins maybe 10 I think would
raise a lot of eyebrows given so many
people had to wear a mask whether they
were on a plane whether they were in
certain public facilities to hear that
they only work at the margins maybe 10
would make a lot of people ask okay then
why was I wearing a mask for so many
times
you know Caitlyn we got to be careful
because if you read very carefully what
I said if you look at the broad Public
Health effect when you have masks that a
so-called mandated is supposed to be
worn because so many people don't wear
them even though they're in an arena in
which masks are supposed to be worn or
they don't wear them properly from a
public health standpoint on the cohort
of people the effect can be only
marginal and as we mentioned it was 10
13 or so but for the individual who
religiously wears a properly fitted mask
the effect is much much much better than
that it's 85 90 or more so we were
trying to distinguish between what the
broad effect on a population is when you
have mask wearing versus the effect on
the individual who religiously and
properly wears the mask there's a big
difference there that's what we were
referring to about on the margins versus
an individual effect of a person yeah
there is a big difference of course like
someone like a doctor someone who's used
to doing this in hindsight though when
you look at this do you think the mass
mandates were were a mistake
you know I want Caitlin I don't want to
say a mistake but I think we really need
to remember next time we're we're
confronted with this that when you have
a situation where there's doubt in the
minds of some people about whether
something works or not we better try to
reach out and be a better explainer of
why we feel these things are important
because whenever particularly in our
country with our
free spirit which we all Embrace that
people being told what to do very often
has the opposite effect that's what I
was referring to in that interview